خففت الصين القيود المفروضه على الرحلات
الدوليه لن تجبر رحله الركاب الدوليه
المتجهه الى بكين الى الدخول الى عبر نقاط
محدد مسبقا ولن يحتاج المسافرون الوافدون
الى الحجر الصحي ولكن لا يزال يتعين عليهم
اظهار اختبار سلبي تم اجرؤه في غضون 48
ساعه من المغادره وسيتم رفع المزيد من
قيود السفر بين البر الرئيسيه السنين وهم
كونج كوماكو ولم يحتاج المسافرون من مكه
الى نتيجه اختبار الكمبيوتر اذا لم يكونوا
في الخارج قبل سبعه ايام من الدخول هذا هو
من المقرر ان تكون هذه الخطوه بمثابه دفعه
كبيره للاقتصاد المحلي بعد ثلاث سنوات من
قيد الغاء قيود السفر ادى الى تعزيز ثقه
الشركات بشكل كبير
اشعر بالحماس حيال هذا القرار والشيء ذاته
بالنسبه لمجموعه من شركات الغرفه
الاوروبيه ويمكن القول انها خطبه ايجابيه
ستكون دفعا بثقه كبيره
على مدار الشهر الماضي شهيدت الصين تحولا
في نظام الصفر كوفيت بعد احتجاجات غير
مسبوقه ضد سياسه شملت اختبارات متكرره
وقودنا على الحركه وعمليه اغلاق واسعه لما
الحق اضرار شسيمه بثاني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم